in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Brandon
and Rachel are with us hey guys how are
you hey we're great
welcome welcome good to have you or do
y'all live Huntsville Alabama very good
very good
and you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes sir I love it how much have
you paid off a hundred and thirty-eight
thousand in three and a half years way
to go
excellent and your range of income
during that time we started around 135
and went up to about 150 by the end
excellent Wow what do y'all do for a
living I'm an auditor for the federal
government and I stay at home with our
boys now but I was a public school
teacher during this timeframe
oh very cool well good for you guys so
what kind of debt was the one hundred
and thirty-eight thousand dollars well
it was a wide variety we had a truck
payment medical bills for a surgery for
Brendan's knee flooring for the house
alone to my parents and then we paid off
her mortgage oh you pay off your house
and everything whoa what's this house
worth about 140 Wow how old are you two
36 36 man and everything is paid for
house and everything I'm looking at
weird people you guys are awesome that
is amazing and so how much of the 138
was the mortgage about seventy-five
thousand okay Wow half of it huh very
neat very neat well way to go you too
very cool tell us the story what
happened three and a half years ago well
it really goes back before that time I
used to do the budget myself and I would
just basically tell Rachel okay we can't
spend any money this month we you know
don't plan on going and doing anything
and that just wasn't a good plan yeah
think I'm gonna match at the end of
every month I would be trying to finagle
numbers and work things around because
she really didn't know anything that was
going on and my oldest brother has
followed you for a long time and I would
kind of ask him acacia know what would
Dave say about this or he would tell me
hey Dave Ramsey says this might be a
good thing to do and eventually I
decided I want to learn that for myself
because I mean rather than have
intermediate in-between I'll just go get
this knowledge myself and I started
listening to the show and about four
years ago I was listening very regularly
and I I got Rachel sat down and kind of
explained to her some of your principles
and the baby steps and just doing things
together as a team and so we agreed that
in January of 2013 kind of as a New
Year's resolution we would start
budgeting together mm-hmm and we just
took off from there getting you know
working multiple jobs and just doing
everything to pay it all off very cool
very cool so he comes in rachel says hey
I think we need to look at this stuff
what'd you say well you can imagine what
I said that I went in January 2013 he
came to me very differently he came to
me in a with love and in love with me
versus just telling me this is the
budget and that would be my hint to
anybody that's not a nerd or not ghazal
intents is to come to your spouse in
love and with love remember this person
is your very best friend you want them
on your team and that this is a marriage
not a business venture oh good for you
ding ding right and when he came to me
like that and he we started the envelope
system - and he came to me and said look
Rach this is your money it was $40 at
the time we called it fun and he gave me
physical control over that money and
that's what I was needing and it also
took him from being the bad cop he no
longer was looking over my shoulder
every time I read the ran the debit card
why did you spend that $2 and 34 cents
at the convenience store and I'm feeling
guilty about it but the same time I'm
angry because hey I bring value to this
family if I want to stop and buy a drink
and a bag of chips I should and so by
him coming to that table and remembering
so what if I give her a little bit of
fun money this month it's bigger it's
about winning the war not these small
battles and you've said that many times
and so one of the keys the biggest key
for us was the budget but doing it
lovingly out of love Chris Brown I'm
just going to turn the show over to her
this is a he's got this ding man I just
boom drop the mic yes there we go very
cool stuff you know a lot of times
people will call in probably the number
one thing that we get on the radio
either my short is is my husband won't
get on the plane or my wife won't get on
the plane and you know we try to tell
folks you know this whole idea of money
management personal finances its money
is a tool not a weapon it's there to
build your marriage not bust your
marriage and I would just say those who
are listening in on the podcast to push
that rewind button and listen to what
Rachel just said over the last two or
three minutes because that is absolutely
huge now right now you guys you know
make it 150 K a year you in a hundred
and forty thousand dollar house that's a
conscious decision because you got ten
grand a month coming in 12 grand a month
coming in and you're choosing not to
upgrade your house now is that going to
change soon well to two parts to that
one she's not working anymore so now
we're down more like a hundred okay but
we our goal is to buy some land and so
we're we're working towards saving for
land we'd like to have a little room for
we have two sons a 4 and a 2 year old
jr. and Colt yeah and we want them to
have some room to roam around and play
so so there's this total go
there's goals and then like you you set
many goals and then you work a plan no
really that simple that simple the Bible
talks about not being just hears of the
word but being doers of the word and as
I hear you guys talk you didn't just
hear principles you put them into work
you put them into practice and very very
admirable and we cheer you on
well we one other thing I wanted to add
to is one of the hardest things for me
during this was being patient and
sticking to those baby steps we have an
emergency fund sitting here before we
had our mortgage paid off and so many
times I want to just reach over there
and put it on that mortgage just get it
going so much faster the day that we
paid off our mortgage that same day we
came home that not put the boys to bed
walked into the kitchen there was an
inch of water in our floor where a
washer had ran over had we spent all
that emergency fund money we wouldn't
have had what we needed to replace our
floor and replace that washer so just
sticking to the plan and the principles
was was
very cool very important if you wouldn't
had that cash you went back to baby step
2 exactly exactly exactly so did you
have a lot of people criticizing what
you were doing or are making fun of you
not to our face we have very supportive
family and friends and a lot of them are
very frugal minded as well and and our
parents we we were very fortunate we
started off our married life debt-free
because our parents gave us our
undergraduate degree degrees and so you
know we were very fortunate that sense
that we started off with that mindset of
taking care of ourselves in our money so
we were very blessed in that sense and
very cool and throughout this process we
actually cash flowed a doctorate and a
master's degree for Rachel so we we
really work as ELLs
what's your doctorate in education
leadership okay Wow
excellent well dr. Rachel thanks for
coming around there cool stuff I love it
very fun all right we have a copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book
because that's the next chapter is
continuing to build wealth and living
like no one else and of course
outrageous generosity goes as a part of
that picture too and Chris is a great
number one best-selling author you'll
enjoy this book so it's signed by him we
appreciate you guys coming up for months
well to do your debt-free scream very
very cool all right it's Brandon and
Rachel Huntsville Alabama a hundred and
thirty eight thousand dollars paid off
house and everything they're not even
forty they're weird then at three and a
half years from 135 to 150 now back to
100 because Rachel's back home full time
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're dead free
great job you two very proud of you
you're heroes
very well done took control of your life
you made the decision to do that folks
you can do that and you can get your
spouse on board and I'm with Chris if
you hit rewind and play back Rachel's
monologue two or three times they're on
how to get your spouse on board you know
you know that this person is your this
is not a business joint venture it's not
a business partnership it's a marriage
and so it's in love and with love is how
you present it very well done very
articulate beautiful beautiful this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you